mavericks owner mark cuban on cnbc
yesterday talking about the inherent
differences between basketball in a
bubble and the nfl in 32 individual
bubbles spread throughout the country
where
the virus is currently raging especially
in multiple areas where where multiple
teams are located uh look chris it's
it's all obvious uh you got more players
you got more people it is going to be
harder to manage it would have been
impossible to do a one location bubble
for the nfl for five months it would
have been impossible they would have had
to commission a location at area 51 yeah
buy one of the hawaiian islands right
they would have had to have done some
because because the more guys you have
the harder it is to keep everybody
inside yeah and all it takes is one guy
who sneaks out gets the virus and brings
it back in and you have a potential
outbreak it's too many people it's too
it would have been way too expensive yes
and and the risk would not have been
driven down to close to zero like it has
been for the nba no no and then again i
mean you know the resources wouldn't be
there and i mean unless you're right
maybe they could take over a city and
that would be like even within that i'm
not sure that you can pull it off like a
full city you know
football fields are bigger than
basketball courts sorry yeah you can go
into the disney wild world of sports
i've done training camp there when i
played for the buccaneers it's ten
basketball courts under one roof and
then another building with other
basketball courts not far from that so
you know
yeah that would be a real issue i don't
know how you could actually pull that
off i don't you know uh maybe maybe they
could have pulled off the one thing i
thought for make maybe divisional you
know bubbles is one thing i thought
about a ways back like if you had an nfc
west bubble or afc west bubble but i
think the nfl is doing the best thing
they can possibly do here and again yeah
it's just too much resources all
together you know nfl teams need many
meeting rooms it's not you know nba can
just go get away with one one room maybe
two and they're fine it's just a totally
different sport that way and yes there's
more of a juggling act and you know
that's why it's
it's interesting like i remember i think
back in the spring with like john
harbaugh and the ravens weren't they
tossing around the idea of maybe they
wanted to go with a little bit of a
smaller roster to not juggle around as
many people you know that that'll be
something that to be watch out for i
mean these coaches are gonna have to get
creative here during training camp to to
get the best out of their teams
and that still hasn't been determined
the size of the rosters for training
camp nflpa leadership had been pushing
for 80. i was told though the rank and
foul wants 90 because why have 320 guys
out of work before we've even shown up
for a single training camp practice so
that hasn't been mentioned a lot of
these issues that have been percolating
haven't been mentioned recently it tells
me those issues are still unresolved
that's one to keep an eye on i had heard
some teams are actually thinking about
voluntarily going with fewer than 90.
you don't have to have 90 90 is the
limit not the minimum so that's another
way to manage the size of your own
individual bubble but you know the
reality is
we've got the basketball players all
gathered in orlando and they are under
tight restrictions to stay put and
they've got an anonymous tip line if
anyone is exiting the bubble basically
going awol off of base
with
the nfl teams
everyone's going to go home at night
and no one's going to know what guys are
doing when they go home at night and i
think that's why the teams that have the
best veteran leadership the highest
level of accountability and i can
imagine tom brady
basically checking in via facetime
with all the young guys on the roster is
he the guy you want to give that example
to it didn't seem like he cared that
much let's think of another guy because
i think i think he is i think he yeah
that's true that's true he is great i
know what you mean because yes he'd be
the guy that would keep people in check
i i understand somebody would have
somebody would have the credibility
right to tell young players what to do
right so
there may be nobody on the tampa bay
buccaneers roster that can pull this off
and they're in florida and you know
that's one inherent difference too
because
some teams are in locations chris
where the bars and restaurants aren't
shut down
other teams are in locations where
there's really nowhere to go right
there's really nothing to do so the
prospect of every night studying your
playbook watching game film playing
video games lather rinse repeat get up
and work the next day
it's you know i i still think that and
we said this yesterday on the question
of chiefs versus the field the the team
that's going to be in the best position
to thrive this year is the team that
loses the fewest number of players to uh
covet 19 positives and have them off off
the roster for one two three weeks at a
time yeah and michael you know something
that you hit on you know back in the
spring too
you know between that and then the teams
that had the least amount of moving
parts in the off season whether that be
coaches or free agents and you know
that's what's funny you look at the two
teams that went to the super bowl their
rosters haven't really changed so
they're really in a good spot the
baltimore ravens hasn't really changed a
lot of the top teams you know stayed
pretty much status quo uh and i think
that'll give them a little bit of an
advantage here going into the into the
2020 season as compared to a team that's
awesome on paper like the bucks but we
know you need to work and and get a
little camaraderie and get on the same
page as a football team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports